In this segment we revisit the
concept of conditional
expectation and view it
as an abstract object
of a special kind.
To get going, let us start with
something simple, the
concept of a function.
Let's say a function
h that maps real
numbers to real numbers.
As a concrete instance,
consider the quadratic
function that maps a number
x to its square.
Consider now a random variable,
capital X. What do
we mean when we write h of X?
For h defined--
for example in this particular
way as a quadratic function--
h of X is defined to be
a random variable.
Which random variable?
It is the random variable that
takes the value little x
squared whenever capital X, the
random variable, happens
to take the value little x.
And this is the random variable
that we usually
denote as the random
variable X squared.
Now let this come to conditional
expectations.
The conditional expectation of
a discrete random variable is
defined by this formula.
It is like the ordinary
expectation except that we now
live in a conditional universe
in which the random variable
capital Y is known to have
taken a value little y.
And therefore, instead of using
the ordinary formula for
expectations that involve the
PMF of X, we now use that
formula but with the conditional
PMF of X, which is
the appropriate PMF
that applies to
this conditional universe.
And if it happens that the
random variable capital X is
continuous, we would have an
alternative formula but of the
same kind, where the summation
is replaced by an integral and
the PMF is replaced by a PDF.
Now let us look at this
quantity here.
We have fixed some particular
little y.
Calculate this quantity.
And what we get is a number.
It is a number, but the value of
that number depends on the
choice of little y.
If I give you a different little
y then you will get
another number for this
conditional expectation.
This means that this quantity
here is really a
function of little y.
And let us give a name
to this function.
Let us call this function g.
Now that we have defined g we
can ask, what is this object?
It's a function of
capital Y. It's a
function of a random variable.
So it should be a random
variable by itself.
By analogy, with the earlier
concrete example, it is the
random variable that takes the
numerical value g of little y
whenever capital Y happens to
take the value little y.
But g of little y has been
defined to be the same as this
conditional expectation.
So it's the random variable
whose value is this
conditional expectation, which
is a particular number, if
capital y happens to take
the value little y.
This particular random variable
that we have defined
here, g of capital Y, we call
it the abstract conditional
expectation of the random
variable X, given the random
variable Y.
To summarize, this notation
here stands
for a random variable.
It is the random variable whose
numerical value turns
out to be this one if the value
of the random variable
capital Y happens
to be little y.
It is a function of capital Y.
Once we know the value of
capital Y, then the value of the
conditional expectation is
well defined.
It is known.
And it's equal to this
particular number.
It is of course a
random variable.
And as a random variable, it
has all the attributes that
random variables have.
For example, it has a
distribution, that
is, a PMF or a PDF.
It has a mean of its own.
And it has a variance
of its own.
So what will be next in our
agenda is to talk about these
attributes of this special
random variable, and also to
use it in several examples.